Speaker 1: But you know, one person who
doesn't ever learn from their mistakes.
Jared Kushner. According to a new report from The
New York Times, it turns out that Jared Kushner
was in fact the individual who gave the
green light to Alex Holder's documentary crew
to come along and film the Trump family starting
in September 2020. And of course, as everybody now
knows, this is the documentary footage that has
been given over the raw footage given over to the
January six committee. They're actually, you know,
meeting with Mr. Holder today behind closed doors.
He's testifying. He's going through footage
with them. They're having a grand old time.
But we don't know exactly what's
in this footage except, of course,
for a little snippet that The New York Times
gave us again. Jared Kushner set this up because
he thought it would be a good, quote, legacy
project for the Trump campaign, the Trump family.
And based on the tiny bit of footage that has been
viewed by the media. We know that, Ivanka Trump
told the documentary crew. That she
actually supported her father's efforts
to overturn the election. Now, that's a bit
of a different story, isn't it? Because from
everything we have seen from her text messages
with Mark Meadows, from her testimony in front
of the January six committee, she
didn't want anything to do with this.
She wanted this to be over. I mean, heck, her
and Jared actually threw a party on the evening
of January 7th, the day after the Capitol riot,
threw a big old dinner party where, according to
reports, nobody even brought up what happened
the day before she washed their hands of it.
Acted like, nope, I was never a part of it, never
wanted anything to do with it, never supported it.
Bill Barr and I had conversations where we talked
about, Yeah, this whole thing is stupid. It didn't
happen. Trump even came out recently attacked
Bill Barr for allegedly corrupting Ivanka
because she was afraid of hurting his
feelings. So she just agreed with him.
That the election was stolen. And now it
turns out that he may have been right.
Because according to this footage, again,
it's been viewed by The New York Times.
Ivanka came out in an interview with
this documentary crew from Alex Holder.
And agreed with the attempts
to overturn the 2020 election.
Now. Again, she told the January six committee a
different story. And she testified to that under
oath. So. Yikes. Right. Hmm. Almost. Almost seems.
Not saying it is, but I'm saying. It seems to me.
I that maybe a little bit of perjury, right?
You can't say one thing under oath, but then
say something else. One of those things is a
lie. And if what you told Congress is a lie.
They know you may have some serious legal
problems on your hands there, Ivanka.
But of course, all the committee could really
do at that point is issue a criminal referral if
they choose to go that route, right. I mean, they
may even look at it and say, I guess we'll just
pointed out to the public how she's a big old liar
and a hypocrite and move on. Which at this point,
you know, who knows what could happen because
we don't know what else is in that footage.
But that's what we do know so far. It's a tiny
little snippet, a tiny little piece of probably
thousands of hours of footage. And so far it looks
pretty bad for the Trump family. How bad you ask